Let us begin please.
Today you should be a fun day for us.
We've got some visitors. It's always, uh,
this particular exercise is one of the
ones that I enjoy most in this course
because we get to talk with
real performers and find
out what's in their head
when they perform a concert for us.
So our aim today is to continue
along this path to make you,
in this case,
educated critics so that you can go to
a concert of classical music and you'll
be able to engage it in
a productive sort of way,
in an educated way. Now there are
lots of things we could think about,
terms of do's and don'ts when we
evaluate material musically in a critical
fashion.
And we're going to be going through
some of those in section starting this
evenings.
And we'll have a big long list of this
is what you put in and review and it's
probably not so good to put this in
a review. But generally speaking,
when you go to a concert
and you review it,
whether you do it just for yourself or
whether you review it and then write down
your thoughts and publish them as a
published review, you do the following.
You're essentially
reviewing the performance.
How well did the performance go?
How did the,
how did the players do?
You're not engaging,
uh, who the composer is.
You're not engaging.
When the piece was written,
the history of the piece,
the historical context,
you're not engaging even oddly
the meaning of the piece,
the meaning of the piece.
Now on our concert for Saturday night,
we have three pieces, one by Mozart,
one by Brahms and one by Beethoven.
What's the meaning of the
Mozart? The opening piece? Well,
the meaning there is
its function in a sense.
It's in trying to get the concert going.
Originally of course he was
trying to get the opera going.
Oddly if the music they're in the overture
has nothing to do specifically with
the music and the opera.
There's no music in the opera.
That's also used in the overture,
but it does have a lot
to do psychologically
because it's a very intense
compressed overture.
And the opera itself,
if you begin to study that in the
way he's linking scenes, in a way,
he's moving his harmonic
progressions along.
It's also a very compressed
intense opera. So, uh,
some of the psychological state of the
opera is encapsulated in that opening
overture, but that overture can open
other things as well. So they're,
the meaning of the Mozart in essence is
the function of the piece to get people
in, to get them quiet,
to get them focused,
and to give them a heads up in a
way as to the psychological, uh,
import of the opera.
That's to follow.
Now we have also the Beethoven,
the pastoral symphony of Beethoven.
What do you suppose the meaning of
that is a pretty straight forward.
Anybody want to take a crack at it?
Anybody know anything about the
pastoral symphony of Beethoven?
What would you guess? What's it sound
like? It sounded like a train, right?
Does this sound like midtown
Manhattan? Elizabeth? Yeah,
the countryside. The kind of
leisurely embrace of the countryside,
maybe a walk through woods on a beautiful
spring day, that kind of thing. Uh,
and each of the moments movements plays
this out in a different way or sort of
an introduction than an introduction
to the birds of the forest.
And the second movement,
uh,
pads and romp in the third movement of
storm gathers in the fourth movement that
we have an extra movement in this
particular symphony because we've got
Beethoven writing a bit of pictorial music
here in the form of a fourth movement
that's a storm and then a
hymn of thanksgiving. Um,
that plays out in basically a Rondo
variation form there at the end.
So that's the meaning of that and
how an individual might embrace the
countryside. A, what's
the meaning of the Brahms?
What's the meeting of the Bronx?
While we've got these variations
and they're simply sonic patterns,
sonic patterns, uh, and we
have patterns, I suppose,
in lots of different arts.
Think of abstract patterns and De
Kooning paintings or Jackson Pollock.
We have a beautiful Jackson Pollock
over in the Yale Art Gallery.
Well that's just sort of abstraction,
visual abstraction as well.
You can have sonic abstractions as well.
I was talking with our conductor
that we'll introduce in a moment, uh,
yesterday about this.
What's the meaning of the Brahms or he
got to this in a different sort of way.
And maybe I will let the cat
out of the bag with that.
But it seems to me that what we've got
here is an individual or an experience in
which we are staying. We have the same
frame of reference, that same context,
in other words,
the theme,
but we're going to engage it in
six or seven really different ways.
And think of all the times in your life,
or you may go into the same context. Uh,
you may go into your dorm room and you've
had a terrible day and you're furious
and you're storming around, or you've
had a very pleasant day, or as it's been,
uh, a rather revenue neutral day
in terms of your emotional content.
So maybe it's not particularly,
uh, moving one way or the other.
You can have the same item that you engage
intellectually or psychologically in
radically different ways.
So this is the same item played out in
rather radically different ways musically
in this theme and variation set.
And we'll say more about that later,
but generally,
oddly you don't write about these kinds
of things when you write a review.
What you're writing about again
is how well they played the piece.
Only if they play it in a way that seems
to subvert the meaning as you perceive
it.
The meaning of the piece is does the
performance a really impact on the meaning
of the piece? Then you might say, well,
this performance was not
successful because as I say
it countermanded or what is
the meaning of this particular
piece as you, the listener, um,
perceive that to be oddly also, you
don't talk about the form in the pieces.
We've,
we've been spending all this time on form.
Form is a way of getting in there so we
can follow along intelligently what's
happening in these compositions.
But we don't write a review in set in
which we say the orchestra started out and
we engaged the first theme and then we
had a fine transition that went to the
second theme.
And I really liked that closing theme.
It had a lot of harmonic bang to it.
We don't want to sort
of be led by the nose,
if you will,
through the form of the piece.
But we'll be saying a lot more
about this in section. And as I say,
we'll have another yet another
sheet, uh, to, to hand to you.
It helps when you go to a concert to know
a little something about the composer.
Right.
What do you know about Beethoven?
What do you think of when
you think of Beethoven?
Yes, the pinnacle of
all music. Okay, good.
That's a, that's an interesting
way of putting it. And actually,
even if you look at the textbook that
you're using there, you've got this,
you've got an entire long chapter
devoted just to Beethoven there and,
but when people write history books,
Beethoven is kind of the Lynch Pin.
You work up to Beethoven in the
new work away from Beethoven.
So Beethoven for the
19th century was, um, uh,
was an icon. It was, um, the,
the pinnacle of what the artist
was supposed to be light.
But it's not just the musical artists.
Beethoven represented more than that.
Uh, was he a neat and tidy guy?
Was he sort of uptight guy?
Did he wear a neck tie and look, look,
sort of a constrained in the, uh,
appropriate system of the day? I'm
the ultimate corporate guy, right?
Was Beethoven the ultimate corporate
guy? No. What did he look like?
He looked like the prototype of the
genius and on the basis of how Beethoven
looked and how Beethoven acted,
people then began to build this concept
of the genius in the 19th century.
Beethoven was the building block for
this whole idea about what a genius was,
how he was supposed to behave, how
he was not necessarily, um, uh,
to be held to the same standards as
the rest of humanity in terms of his
behavior to other people.
If you had unnecessary to be
dishonest, be dishonest. He,
Beethoven wasn't a serve as dishonest
as sometimes with regard Wagner was,
but it was excused
because he was a genius.
Well this sort of idea begins with
Beethoven here in the 19th century.
What did Beethoven, right, well,
as you can see on your sheet there,
but you pick up your sheet.
I think I've got a find it useful
to do this from time to time.
Just sort of the basic Beethoven if
you will. Um, and a list of things.
If you want to buy particular pieces
or you want to explore particular
repertoire of Beethoven, well you
can do it in this fashion. So, um,
there is,
uh,
what we need to know about Beethoven
on that particular sheet bronze.
We talked about, we talked
about his pieces. Mozart,
we will be talking a lot more
about, um, as time goes on,
now we have,
let's turn to our big sheet here.
What are you going to do with
this big sheet, isn't it?
You can do a couple of
things with that big sheet.
An energetic student
might want to go out and
go to iTunes and do what
and before the concert. Yeah. Download by.
Get the pieces ahead of time. Um,
for 99 cents, except with the,
with the Beethoven.
Why would the Beethoven cost more?
Bye.
Yeah. You got to pay for each of the
movement as the way they sell their stuff.
Stuff too. And once again, they'll call
them soul, right? Each is Ebay. Pardon?
And you can go to the music library
because Linda has been kind enough to put
all of these on reserve for all
these pieces on reserve for us also.
So you have this big sheet and uh,
you can take this,
you can engage this material
ahead of time with the pieces.
We don't have any of these
pieces on our cds there.
Thousands of zillions of
classical pieces of music.
We can't put them all on our cds.
We have Beethoven's all of Beethoven's
Fifth Symphony, for example,
but we don't have the sixth symphony.
But you can get it there
on iTunes if you want to.
And then you can follow along and ask
yourself these questions as you're
listening to a recording before
the contract. That would be,
that would be a really, um, uh, uh,
serious type of preparation for this,
uh,
feeling that you could simply
bring this to the concert.
Simply bring this to the
concert and then, um, uh, uh,
follow along of discretely as the concert
is going on and ask yourself these
questions and maybe write on it.
Probably be good if we didn't
have a hundred people going
like this during the middle of the concert
and we get on the change of peace or
some change of movement.
So try to keep the,
I've seen also students sit there with
computers sort of taking notes during it.
That's, that's a bit over
the top it seems. It seems to
me. So it'd be really neat.
Uh,
somehow what I do actually,
what do I do when this is going on because
I have to read these reviews, right?
I got to read them, so I got to know
and the TA's have to know what happened.
What I do is I take my program and I
do have a pencil there and they take my
program and I'll write little notes on
my program so that I can remember what
the orchestra did at a particular spot.
And generally speaking,
the sooner you write your review
after a performance, uh, the better.
Um,
so do you have questions about that
and we'll be talking more a lot about,
about that intersection, uh,
starting this evening. Yes. Dan,
how long did it reviews be? 500
words. Two pages. Very good question.
We're going to hold you to, that holds
you to that. So they're not long,
but it forces you to think about what's
important and what's not important when
you write.
Uh,
Roger,
um, I, I basically you're writing
about how well they perform. Um,
at the end of it,
you could throw in a sentence or
two to the effect that they met your
expectations as to the meaning of this
composition as the composer intended it
or they did not,
but I would not spend a lot of
time engaging in the review. Uh,
the meaning of the piece.
No.
So we'll, we'll, we'll,
you've got the five pieces here and
we'll be going over some more of them in
section and getting you up to speed
in terms of, of the repertoire as,
as time goes on. Any other questions
before we introduce our first guest?
Yes.
That's to be encouraged.
In other words,
if you hear this opening overture going
to Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. That, that the data that
that's way too slow. I'm not feeling
it compressed. I'm feeling excited.
I'm not feeling energized by that tempo.
So you should say there then I
think the tempo was too slow.
Yeah,
it didn't,
if the music didn't have energy,
it didn't excite the listener because
the initial tempo was too slow.
Anything else? Well, if not,
let's go on to introduce our
first guest then Bradley Nailer.
Here's Bradley's name up there.
Bradley is the Prince of Kimono friendly.
Bradley is the principal
conductor for tomorrow night,
and we will be listening
to the Saybrook orchestra.
And the rest of our discussion today is,
uh,
basically between you and Bradley
with me feeding Bradley questions.
I'm trying to think about the kinds
of things that you might want to ask,
but don't hesitate to jump right in
and raise your hand and ask Bradley a
question at any point. So, Bradley, you're
a student at the school of music, right?
Uh, so tell us about your musical
training. How'd you get started here?
I sang in choirs,
gosh,
it was probably eight when
I started singing in choirs,
but it wasn't until middle school
that I started getting serious.
My middle school music teacher said,
Hey Brad,
why don't you try out for this region and
choir thing? And then I go, okay, I'll,
I'll submit a tape.
And I got there and here
I was in this room of 25,
15 year old tenors and they were all
seeing the same notes at the same time.
And I thought, well,
that's just a miracle.
And so I felt that that point
I'd really found what I to do.
Um,
went to high school,
went to Undergrad where I majored in
music just down the road in Providence.
And I got a master's degree in choral
conducting at Indiana university out in
the cornfields.
And now I'm back in New England getting
an m and a master of musical arts and
choral conducting at the Institute
of Sacred Music. So the your,
for your preparation for this is a
little bit unusual for most conductors
because I think,
uh,
rarely are only exceptionally,
do you have people beginning in music
through vocal music, they'd come around.
Now you're,
you're leading an orchestra here,
so doesn't that put you at
something of a disadvantage?
I would think to be an
orchestral conducted be really
good to have started with
the violin or maybe the French horn.
So you're listening to intonation
issues and things like that.
I would agree with that. Um, I can't, well
with the exception of maybe Robert Shaw,
I can't think of a single
big name conductor who
started as a choral conductor
and now is in charge of a,
a major symphony orchestra.
The vast majority of them are either
string players, keyboard players,
a few wind or brass players
here and there. But, um,
I've done a few things to
try and supplement that
perceived lack of knowledge.
Um,
when I was an Undergrad,
I took an orchestration class to try
and get a sense of what the capabilities
and limitations of all the instruments
were. A couple of summers ago,
I spent a month at Bard
College in New York at a,
an instrumental conducting workshop
where I worked with various conductors.
So I've tried to supplement that
a, that initial coral leaning. Um,
but what about piano now?
I mean,
I'm always surprised how good
pianists these conductors are.
So you must have had to practice
piano, don't take piano, piano.
Um,
I wouldn't say extensively,
but consistently throughout
my young career. Um,
because you have to, in
order to, to engage the music
and we'll talk about this,
you have to be able to do,
what was the score?
I think you have to be able to play
or realize the full score, right?
So it might be the kind of thing we
would put a score with maybe 20 lines up
there on the,
on the keyboard here.
And Bradley would be able
to read through this.
And Digest all these 20 lines at once.
You pick doesn't sound
all that difficult except,
except a lot of these lines
are not actually written.
The notes that are written there are
not the ones you play because they're
transposing instruments such as the beef,
flat clarinet in the beef flat trumpet.
So it's really complicated.
In fact,
Ooh, Ooh, that hurts. That would
be like reading a text, uh,
in four languages at once.
You know,
one word is in Cyrillic alphabet
and next the Latin alphabet.
Next Hebrew alphabet.
So your mind has got very quickly
to change all this really hard.
It takes years and years and years and
years of preparation. Well, what do you,
what's your goal here?
What do you want to do with this?
Where do you want to be 15 years
from now? Oh, well, I don't
know if there's a white
picket fence, but, um,
I would like to be teaching at
a university directing choruses,
working on choral orchestral works,
like maybe Haydn's creation or something
like that at a great piece from the
same period as Beethoven's symphony. So,
uh, working at a, at a university, right.
College level as well as maybe a
professional chorus or orchestra. Okay.
Now here's a question for it might
seem like a route one, but I,
I get to my class, I get to
be ruined if I want to. Um,
what makes you think you can do this
better than anybody else who says that
you'll get to be the boss here?
The leader here?
A isn't that a bit of Hubris on,
on your part? I think that any conductor
has a bit of Hubris in him or her.
Um,
I guess the short answer to that is
that whenever I sit in a rehearsal,
I'm using my ears. Whenever I sit in
and rehearsal and I'm not conducting,
I'm using my ears to try and
evaluate what's coming back.
And I always find myself
forming an opinion. You know,
this could be loud or
this could be softer.
I want to hear that more than I
want to hear this other thing.
So the only place you can achieve that
goal is if you're in front of the house.
Yeah. Oddly, that's what
they will be doing though.
When they go to this country,
you guys will be listening and say, gee,
why didn't I love that flute line there?
Uh, why wasn't that Flute Line
Louder? So he's kind of a critic,
but he wants to apply his critical
facility here to interpretation.
So that's it. To impose his
concept of the music, um,
on others for the benefit of others.
I said,
well, what do they have to have
to conduct? What's it take to be?
What's it take to be a good conductor?
You think?
Just just that you've got a good
insights into the music. Um,
well I have, I think just a
good insights into the music.
Music is youtube readily,
but,
but I don't think I would be any good
as a conductor and I kind of know why.
So what do you have to do? What do you
have to have to be a good conductor?
I think it's a varied skillset,
I think,
and don't tell my colleagues I'm
saying this, but I think at its basis,
the conductor is really just a
glorified traffic cop in certain ways.
Trying to make Sur that
there are no accidents.
You don't want the logos to crash into
the bassoon. So nobody wants that.
You have to make sure that
people yield when they need to.
If you need to hear the viola line,
you've got to have the violence yield. Um,
and you just have to make sure that
everyone gets to their locations without
incident and a,
and as fluid.
Yeah. Okay, good. Now here's a, here's a,
another component of this though I've
heard of people and talk about in terms of
books, I have absolute rhythmic, um,
sort of an absolute sense of rhythm.
I can tell what a particular pulse is.
I can identify that for
you and I can keep that.
And that's why I'm interested in,
in becoming conductor or
let's say you're conducting,
and this is where I would always go.
What I have done some conducting,
used to conduct the collegium here at Uw.
But where I got in trouble was when
something was out of tune, I could, hey,
that doesn't
sound good,
but I couldn't tell them why or
what to do to make it sound right.
My ear wasn't good enough. So, uh,
how good an ear do you have to
be to be a conductor? How good,
how good do you have to have an ear,
not just for pitch,
particularly with an orchestra,
but also for timber. Ah,
which is the property that distinguishes
maybe an oboe sound from a clarinet
sound. Of course, if
you're playing a piano,
then
you can't change the Tambour
of a single piano note.
But if you're playing it on a clarinet,
it's going to sound very different
than if you played on the trumpet.
So you have to be able to balance tambors.
And I think before the downbeat
of the first rehearsal,
a conductor really has to have the sound
of the piece in his or her ear. So, so,
so I know what needs to be pulled out.
You know,
maybe the third clarinet is a little
bit sharp. So I say third clarinet,
your B flat makes sure
it doesn't sit too high.
So I think you have to have the piece
in your, in your head. There's a,
an old conductors mantra always had the
score in your head and not your head and,
well, okay, there are all kinds of
things I get asked you about their, uh,
what are you going to do in New York?
You're the principal conducted and you're
doing two of the three pieces you're
doing the first half you're doing the
Mozart and the Brahms and then, uh,
Lauren Quigley will come out.
She couldn't be with us today,
but Lauren quickly we'll come
out and lead the debate over.
Are you going to try to conduct
any of this without a score?
And what advantages and disadvantages?
Sometimes you go to concerts and
a reviewer might notice that. Um,
generally speaking, if you see a
conductor conducting without of score,
what does that indicate?
Well,
I think it's always impressive to the
ensemble when a conductor's able to
conduct without a score. Uh,
last year Helmut [inaudible],
who's a famous German conductor,
came and worked with some of the
ensembles and didn't Mendelssohn's Elijah,
which is a huge romantic oratorio
about two and a half hours long.
The dress rehearsal,
he came to the dress rehearsal,
put a score down on a music
stand, conducted for three
hours, never opened it.
We were like, wow, this
guy knows the score.
So my task is to try to get four and a
half minutes of Mozart into my head so I
don't have to open that score. We'll see
tomorrow if I'm able to do it. Um, yeah.
So that's sort of talent.
And so that's a kind of combination of a
photographic memory and a phono graphic
memory that you've got to,
you've got locked in there,
you can hear something just
once and it's locked in there.
That's the kind of thing Mozart could do
and we'll talk more about that later on.
Um,
and so your,
your orchestra will respect you more
if you've got this all memorized. Uh,
what does it, what does it sort of
free you up to do that? Obviously,
if you've got,
if you're conducting without a score,
I think, I think at its, at its essence,
conducting is communicating to the people
in front of you and anything that you
can get out of the way,
uh,
between you and the people who are
playing the music is, is an advantage.
So I think getting the
music stand out of the,
you're getting the score of the way.
Making sure that they're all times you
can actually see the people who are
making this music. I think anything you
can do to do that is an advantage. Yeah.
Great.
Um,
I want to go back to this question
though of ear because I think it's so
critical. You were talking about the third
clarinet. Don't play too sharp. Well,
once again, I'd be sitting there
it who's playing what it's wrong.
Wondering. All right. Is it the oboes
maybe said the clarinet being sharp,
the oboes flat. All I hear is a
problem. I don't know what, where,
what are the problem is. So, um, uh,
but so you would have to have
a pretty keen sense of pit.
Do you have what we call absolute pitch?
I don't have absolute pitch.
I had a pretty creative
relative. Okay. So, um,
I always enjoy playing
this particular game with,
with musicians and people generally where
we do an ear training drill and I need
somebody, uh, is it Michael?
I just need somebody to come up and
play the piano. And just for your bank,
some notes on a panel run.
Who, who uh, Daniel, you know,
do you know your way around a keyboard?
You're, you're a guitar player. Sure.
Anybody play,
uh,
a gentlemen here? Come on
up. Yeah. Okay. Come on up.
And you know what? Yeah, so we're
going to be over here, um, uh, and um,
Adam come play this game also.
Linda,
you want to play this down?
You go in terms of of pitch.
You're name is Robert.
Yeah. Um, so, um, uh,
and, and Jacob, come on,
come on out here also, um,
play it started around Middle C and
we'll see if anybody can identify any.
Linda,
you don't want to play.
I'd like to have some ladies up here to
Santana when you come on up and play the
name,
that pitch game,
and we'll talk about absolute pitch and
we'll talk about relative pitch. So,
so play a note and we'll see how we do.
Oh, it's up to you. A note
that's a little lower.
Okay.
Does anyone think they
know what the note is? But,
but don't have anybody up here
think they know what it is,
I would guess, but, right.
Um, Bradley, you think
you know what it is? Yeah,
but I had two guesses in whichever
one I say is going to be wrong.
I think it's either g or a g sharp.
Uh, what, what do you guys think?
Okay. Okay. Um, notice
how cagey I am here.
I haven't committed. Um, yeah.
Uh, but, but just at the outset,
he played at initial pitch and then what
did he do? He dropped it down an optic.
Okay. So we think that that's, uh, that's
probably isn't a flat or a g sharp,
is that correct? Yep. Okay.
Now knowing that play another pitch.
Hmm. Go ahead, rob.
Anybody know what that is?
Uh, so then the question is, why is
this guy teaching this course? Right?
Why is he in this profession
to begin with? Because,
because he's wrestled with this
issues and all his life is it, why me?
Why can't I do this?
And tried to figure it out.
Tried to try to use other
tricks too to get around this,
to overcome this handicap and
to hang around with musicians,
sort of explain things that they do,
that they take in sort of quickly and
intuitively that and sort of break them
down and explain what it is that
they're doing. So at this point,
Bradley seems not to be having
a trouble with that pitch.
I don't know what it is to be that.
I could, I could g no. All right.
All right. Uh, so I'm out, down, down.
I go. Um, but what was that pitch?
C sharp. Okay. Um, uh, all right,
so let's say now knowing that
that's a c sharp, let's see how far.
Let's go and we'll go a little
faster here. So we don't really,
we don't take up too much time.
Another person
who knows that Bradley Jacob,
we should have them write it on the board,
who doesn't know what it is.
Santana.
Anybody know who, what do you think it is?
What do you think it is? I'll go with t.
So I, but what, what, what
was it? Was it, did you, okay.
So it seems to me that actually Bradley
seems to be winning here. He's tea.
This is interesting. Uh, so maybe there
is a reason that he's the conductor here.
The rest of I'm out the rest of this or
are there kind of negotiating with each
other and maybe pegging off
of what Bradley was saying
there. So we'll stop this,
but, okay. Thanks guys.
Whenever I do here think,
well,
what song does that start?
Or is there a a quarter snorting
it? Which I'm committed. I know,
for instance, so do you mind if
I just, sure. Thanks very much.
So for instance,
that first note is a g sharp.
So I know that the first, uh, the
first Aria in Handel's Messiah
starts with a really prominent g
sharp and the melody. Yana kind of,
I kind of know how that sounds. So
that's how I figured that was a g sharp.
That's the second note he played was a
c sharp or d flat and there's this great
for aps,
this great d flat.
So I kind of find a piece that I,
that I can latch onto
that's very interesting.
In all the years I've been
doing that, I, I haven't heard
that particular explanation for it.
You know,
most people that have absolute pitch boom,
they hear it instantaneously.
There's someone in this room
also was absolute pitch,
but I don't want to go go into instances
of absolute pitch or about one in
10,000, one in 10,000 sort
of instantaneous recognition.
He's getting that,
but in a different way.
He must have some kind of absolute wreck
recollection of particular pieces that
are intentionally, um, impressed
on his oral memory somehow.
And he then plays off of those that,
that's an interesting way of doing it.
But as I say, it's not something I've
encountered before. Ah, okay. Well,
so that's kind of important though.
You've got to have a good ear like that
to be able to tell these people your
sharp or flat.
Now let's say you're in the middle
of things and something goes wrong.
You Ha you have a sense that you're,
you know that your clarinet is a little
bit flat. W what do you, what do,
you can't just hold up a sign or
an arrow going like this, can you,
or maybe maybe you can.
How do you get it in real time as the
pieces that you're conducting and the
pieces unfolding.
How do you get somebody to correct
something in terms of intonation?
I think that there's a difference
between what you're doing,
a rehearsal in what you're doing, a
performance and rehearsal. You'd say,
hold up the grants,
pause and saint clarinet three fix that
in a performance you hope that you have
inculcated in your performers a sense of,
of pitch and a sense of
what their function is.
An accord so that if something's going
wrong, you just look at them and say, yes,
you know you're wrong. Fix it cause you
can't stop. You know the traffic cop.
If you don't look at the Subaru over here,
he's going to crash into a tree.
So you have to take care of everybody.
But the guy who's running the stop sign,
you had to take care of that person first.
So, um, let me ask this.
Oftentimes you go to a concert,
particularly, um, non professional
concerts at the end of a movement,
they will stop and tune if
we hear in the Beethoven, uh,
the tuning between movements,
there's,
is that a sign that the intonation and
the previous movement wasn't all that it
might've been?
Hmm.
Um,
I think it's a bigger problem
with early instruments that are,
that are a little bit more temperamental.
But certainly if we stop in the middle
and you hear Gabriel Ellsworth give us a,
and we return, then yes. So
that, that would be a pig. No, I just had
no problem.
Okay. Um, uh,
so there are some things that you can
can do in real time and uh, things that,
uh, uh, that you just hope that
you prepared for pro properly,
but keep an eye on that. Whether they,
whether they actually tuned between,
between movements though now I think we
have some other folks who are going to
demonstrate some things here.
I think we have Katie, uh,
driving the v a viola player. The
principal. Okay. Katie, come on up.
And I don't know if Elana Kagan
is here or not. She here. Flutist.
Oh my mind.
Maybe she's sleeping in whole too bad.
I said I doubt it, but I don't think
so. I just don't know. I guess it,
I guess it's only, maybe, maybe it's
only five after. So we do have, let's,
let's talk about the motor. We're
going, we've got this opening piece. Um,
uh, first of all, which piece of
the two frightens you the most?
You're the conductor. What
are you worried about? What,
what scares you when you
should step out there? Well,
what's easy about the Mozart?
Okay, no tempo changes. Fine.
So the whole piece is in this,
in the same tempo problem.
If you don't set the right tempo, you're
screwed for four and a half minutes.
When I do de de, De,
De, De, De, De, De, De,
I have to get that dead on so that the
whole ensemble knows exactly what the
tempo is. But okay, but look, let's say a
mess it up in the first couple of beats,
can't you correct it.
I think a,
a good critic as you will all be, would
say, well this is classical music,
mister nailer and there's nothing in the
score that says writ or a cello, Rondo.
So actually you should keep whatever tempo
is established at the beginning. Yeah.
So you're not tempted
to get out there and go
like that and know that, I'm always
impressed when conductors, they come out,
they kind of look at the orchestra and
they go and they just start without much
in the way of preliminary beats. But
that's a, that's kind of risky isn't it?
But, uh, what am I conducting?
Teachers told me, you know,
there's no part in the score
that's labeled conductor,
so you shouldn't do anything other than
what's going to get the people in front
of you to play. So there's no point in
the beginning going one, two, three, four,
[inaudible] did an internet because then
you have a conductor solo for two bars
and it's not in the score. So,
um, so, uh, let's see. Katie,
come on up. And do we have a
stand for you? Did we not? Well,
I'm sure we got one inside here.
Similar. Linda maybe are, but no, no.
Um, well you brought one. Okay.
Get your standout because we've got
the beginning of the overture to, um,
uh, the marriage of Figaro here. Shall
we, should we play a CD of it or you have,
maybe we could, let's talk about
Lindt. Well, I tell you what, well,
Katie's getting her stand.
I, let's talk about Linda.
She's got a bassoon part here. What
happens at the beginning of this, uh,
Bradley in terms of,
of the texture.
Monophonic homophonic
polyphonic monophonic. Why?
Because all of the instrument,
there are many instruments playing,
but they're all playing the same
line at the same time. Okay. So,
but isn't that a little bit awkward
because some of these instruments sort of
speak a lot faster than
other instruments? Uh, vast,
but what would the fast
speaking instruments, but
they could play very agilely.
What would they be? I think the violence
probably had the easiest time of this,
whereas the celli and the bassoon probably
have the toughest time of this cause
it takes lower instruments longer
for them to speak and make,
make their sounds so,
um,
the cellos and basses and the,
the low part of the woodwinds and might
have a difficult time here. So we, uh,
Linda has been good enough
to be a sacrificial lamb
for today and bring in her
bassoon. And she sent me an email
last night and say, oh, disaster,
I cracked my only good read and I'm
not gonna I'm not going to bring in,
I can't bring in my bassoon.
It just won't work. Does it?
Come on when I was really counting on
this. Please bring in your bassoon.
So here is,
here is uh,
Lynda with a broken reed and um,
hi, are you a lay in there? Okay, come
on up. Come on up. Great. But, so, um,
just come on up and take out your,
your flutes and we'll get out the,
the music here in just a second. So let's,
can we have the beginning of, of the, uh,
of the figure. Oh, do you want to
conduct this or, or no, heavens,
this is chamber music. I said, okay,
how about I give you a template
and then you guys go to town
and again, and again, I
think, I think Linda for,
for doing this because it's not,
it's not an ideal situation.
All right,
so here's the safe conservative tempo
about that editing, editing,
editing, not that bad.
One,
two,
the,
Huh,
cool.
Wonderful.
[inaudible]
great. The music one 12
orchestra. Um, now you said, well,
here's a conservative safe tempo,
but what,
what, what happens if you don't
take a safe tempo? What, uh,
what kind of disasters might befall us?
Well,
I think in this case there
wouldn't be a disaster.
It just wouldn't go as fast as I had set
up. So, uh, I have a recording of, um,
I think it's James Leviathan and the
metropolitan opera opera orchestra,
highest paid orchestra in the country.
And they take this at a blistering tempo.
Yeah,
really fast. Yeah. Let's
see how close we can get.
Uh,
how fast you can take something.
Sometimes is conditioned by the
acoustical environment that you're in.
And maybe we'll come back to that about
the acoustics of Patel a little bit,
a little bit later on.
Um, now, uh, let's see.
Katie, you're a violist and
um, you're the principal.
Violist.
Then I wanted to ask you,
your job is to kind of ride roughshod
over the rest of the violas here.
Um, and how do you do,
isn't it like hurting
rattlesnakes or something like that hat?
Supposing you want to get your section
to be really precise and really exact and
all those boats going up and down at the
same time. The articulation, exactly.
Exactly the way they should be. Uh,
how do you go? You lead by example,
but in the actual performance,
how do you keep your, your,
the rest of those deal with you?
The principle,
oh, well, you have to be very
confident about what your plan,
you can change your mind. So you need
to know what you need to come in,
what you knew,
which direction your go in and
show that when you're playing
just by being confident.
And so then the rest of the people
who know that part's very well. Um,
but well can call you if they get
off and we'll have that little bit of
assurance come in.
Great. How do we know that they
know their parts really well?
What would you imagine might be a tip off?
And you're,
you're at a concert and you're watching,
you're looking what's going look,
what would it be a tip off to? Maybe
they don't know their parts really well.
They're sitting there with their nose
in the music rather than watching the
conductor. The more the
orchestra is watching the
conductor for the cues and the
interpretation, the more that says, Hey,
they've really got this almost committed
to memory. Uh, and they can get in.
They can get beyond the notes into
the question of interpretation there.
Another thing is just a
very basic thing is the,
Katie has mentioned here is watching,
she wants to have very prominent bro
boasts strokes. I guess so that everybody,
the whole section will
be in sync if you see,
see this kind of thing in
terms of the bowl movement,
maybe the articulation really isn't
altogether there. They should, all,
each of these sections should be going
there pretty much the same way it was
that, right? Yeah.
And particularly with the
string instruments, there's
a different sound with the
okay.
Up Is it in term as opposed to a down bow.
So an oppose,
we'll start very small at down,
but you can start very
gruffly. So it does make a
difference. So, um, uh, uh, Katie,
let me ask you this. Generally speaking,
all don't have solos in the repertoire,
so what's the hardest thing for
you to play there Saturday night?
What scares you?
Here's me. Wow. Like you
said, we don't have solos,
but we are very important to me that we
of the upper and the lower strings and
other parts are together.
Um,
and I think other perceptions get used
to hearing us play certain parts and when
we're not there.
Yeah.
That's not only true for
violist. Yeah, pretty much.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
You're kind of like the glue
and particularly I would
imagine rhythmically is
the,
if you,
you might be setting really setting the
tempo when these other extreme high,
lower play them off of the rhythmic
tempo that you're setting, setting,
they're in the middle.
What's the most different?
Is there any moment that you sort of get
to soar with some music that you like
particularly what, what's your favorite
moment? Most beautiful moment for you?
Can you play a little that rolling.
Okay.
Um,
and the apartment or we have the melody.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
And that's kind of fun.
Yeah.
Well I guess it's like maybe the right
guard of the left guard on a football
team.
Nobody ever notices,
but to actually crucial to the overall
running of this operation. Um, okay.
Now we have also with this,
uh, thank you Katie. Be also,
we have with this the principal flutist
right to Elena Kagan and you've got some
heavy duty exposure,
particularly in the Beethoven
second movement with all
of those solos there. Uh,
so here's a question for a Katie with,
excuse me,
Elena w with the Solos that you have
to play. Do you ever get nervous?
Of course, definitely. I mean,
when you really have a solo on your
fingers and you don't have to be nervous,
it makes it even more fun and you can
always play better when you're not so
focused on that. So I certainly
try to get beyond being nervous.
But then that's definitely there.
And the trickier it is,
the more nervous I get.
Well what happens to the
playing when you get nervous?
How can we recognize that
you're nervous or you can't?
But I mean a lot of times messing
up is a sign of being nervous.
Is there a lot of players who will get
it right every time and rehearsal and
then just the nerves of the concert?
Yeah, that was me. I always said I was
the world's greatest warm up pianist
and then you get to the moment you have
to play and nerves kick in the, you know,
just his little fractions of
inches on these instruments.
The question of life and death.
So if your,
if your head is it all quivering and
can imagine a little violin, they,
I did you get this huge vibrato or,
so where did this come from? Um, okay.
So let's, uh, let's, um, uh,
he or if we, if we may, Ilana,
some of the, um, the lovely,
lovely imitations of bird calls,
they're in the second movement
of the Beethoven. Um, what would,
what would be good for you to, um, to
play, choose anything that you like?
So this is Beethoven second
movement theme and variations and,
okay.
Well there's, if there's one part at the
end that definitely sounds like, okay,
you have the interesting,
I guess a duet with declare an end that,
that sort of thing. Or is that
what you're talking about? The end.
There's a lot of intricacies
between the hope,
the wind instruments having conversations.
Um,
so I can play a couple of those parts.
Yeah.
You'll hear lots of cascading
other woodwinds they choose
me is really just said
with the oboe and the Clearnet sort
of dialoguing against this, um,
intonation here.
Do you guys practice this individually?
Do you have what we would call sectionals
where you get together and work this
out or you only do this
with the full orchestra?
Well, we actually haven't had
analysis. That's certainly very common
to have sectionals to work it out.
But this semester we mostly just worked
on it on our own and as a full orchestra.
Uh Huh.
Um, one the one thing
instruments are out of tune.
Is it that the Bradley,
what do you think?
Is it often the woodwinds
that get out of tune?
Um, I think that, uh, you know, I
don't want to lay blame or it's not do,
but I think that sometimes it's easier
for instruments that you can press down
to key and no more or less the right
support, what note is going to come out.
But if you have a string
instrument with no frets,
like a guitar has frets on its fingerboard
but violence and all the string
family don't. So that's a little bit
more guesswork. So it's really difficult,
especially in fast passage work like
Katie was playing earlier to get a uniform
intonation across the section.
So we have really only about two more
minutes left and I'd like to make the
following point.
One of the things you should be on the
look out for is balance over there and
what the French horns are doing because
this is a really exposed instrument and
they're probably going to be up there
on risers and that sound tends to Blair
fourth and in Patel. So keep an eye out
for the French horns. They're really,
really be exposed.
Um,
I have one other line of development here,
but I want it before we go.
Does anybody out there have a question
that you would like to ask Bradley or
Katie or Allana?
Yeah.
All right, let me, uh, ask, asked them
this question. Where should we sit?
What are the acoustical
issues involved in Battelle?
Do we want to sit so we can see? And
that's not bad. You might say, Hey,
well I'll get way up in the front as
far as I can and watch this in this
intricate orchestra, this great grand
machine firing on all cylinders,
cylinders here, or do I want
to go all the way to the back?
And maybe just push away the
visual and just enjoy the sale.
Because oftentimes in concert halls,
the best sound is not a front
sailing sailing right over your head.
It's coalescing in the back of the hall.
So where should we sit?
Well,
my favorite place to sit in concerts,
so somewhere where I can
see that interaction between
the different, I guess,
gears in the machine as well. Um, so, uh,
I would sit somewhere not
directly behind the conductor.
So somewhere where you can see the
players because they're the ones actually
making the music.
Yeah.
So if you want to go second balcony
all the way down as far as you can go,
you can actually get up
in front of the conductor.
You can be almost being the
orchestra that way. Now,
what about the acoustic last issue
here? The Acoustics in Patel, are they,
are they pretty good,
favorable?
Well,
it doesn't matter.
Do you have trouble hearing while they're
certainly different than the runway
practicing?
Um,
which is why we have a dress rehearsal
so that we can adjust our sound according
to the acoustics of the room
that we're playing in. Um,
but I think, uh, Patel is a lot
more live, meaning that, um,
the sound sort of like live as long.
Yeah. It's resonance. It has a very long
reverberation cycle. How do we cut down?
How can you help the orchestra?
What would you guess what would be the
best way you can help the orchestra to
bring clarity to their sale and
actually allow them to play faster,
get that tempo with the
Mozart to go faster.
If you've got a wall more
verberations cycle, little hall,
your tempo will go slower.
What can you do to help out here now?
That 40 and thing, what
would you do? Wear a sweater.
Bring a teddy bear. Bring your friend,
bring your mother, grandmother.
Bring as many people.
Get as many sound absorbing bodies
in there as you possibly can.
So we'll see you then Saturday night,
eight o'clock and thanks to our guests.
Okay.